[Music]
uh
hello everyone thank you very much for
having me here
i'm going to talk about wave surfer for
audio notation in r
a little bit my by myself i'm working
equivalent working
on my masters on the theme automatic
bird species recognition based on their
songs
and to tackle this problem i chose
supervised machine learning of course
and to do so i needed label data
one can split the machine learning
project workflow in these three parts
extraction data annotation and modeling
and i
think that we are pretty well served in
terms of tools
in the data extraction and modeling we
have warbler which is a outstanding
package for
bioacoustics you have all the tightverse
ecosystem
keras tensorflow everything
but i had a really hard time labeling my
data
in art annotating so wave surfer
was an attempt to bridge this gap
okay what is uh i think there's a
missing image here but what is wave
surfer is
the javascript library too for making
beautiful audio visualizations for the
web
and it also has a rich set of plugins to
work with
so it's pretty cool and active in the
community
here's what i did it was just an html
widget for this library which has this
pipe above api and i also implemented
the
plugins uh the most important one which
would make me choose this library was
the
annotator or the region plugin which
allows you to draw out
some areas on your audio
representation and also label it so it's
perfect for the task right
this square this yellow region is
an example of the annotation
another cool feature is that you can
visualize spectrogram instead of the
sound waves which is
important for us in this task uh one
cool thing
is that this representation is not
available in the original js i
tweak it a little bit this part is cool
but dangerous because i'm not
very skilled in the javascript coding
but this is the api what i would like to
to highlight now is the annotator app
which
provides to anyone to the researchers to
start annotating their own audios right
away without knowing
shiny and stuff
this requires just two inputs
the path to the wave files folder and
the patch the do
where you want to store the annotated
annotations
and it is what it looks like
i'm going to zoom in some key parts here
is the
main part of the the app is where you
you're going to
do the actual notation with the point
and click
resize drag and drop in stuff
this is the the width get itself here's
some metadata where is the the
the folders and some switches like
bigger spectrogram or
auto saving this is the standard
controllers of any media player this
table
is a uh where you can navigate through
your
wav files and you can select
the file you want to annotate and also
tells if
whether the audio was
annotated already or not the green is
the are the annotated audios
here's just the feedback of what we're
going to start to use it later on
and this finally is the what i call the
region suggester which is a cool feature
to
uh that will draw for you automatically
regions that it thinks is a event that
you are looking for
so it's free make your life easier and
your job
quicker some project calls i won't would
like to
highlight the the fact that you can put
it on the cloud and make this
a laborious part of the job
collaborative so it can
scale your job pretty much
and this is it thank you very much this
is a work in progress so
reach me out in github and thank you
very much
you